so last week i showed you a game that i
had in
rethy and i thought that was kind of
cool to um
take some time and go over that it ended
up taking
all of our time so
um the other game that i have prepared
for you
and we are gonna hopefully take a look
at
both of them today so um
all right i am quite excited so um
this game was i played it i'm black i
played against the grand master
and mart take me mark take me yes
open in 2015 so like um martini open
from i remember was right after
um so we played bill tournament then it
was like a short break and then we went
to martini to play that so for those of
you who
are trying to plan your next summer
maybe that's something you can do
all right um it wasn't quite it was kind
of
short um it was i think it was seven
rounds and it was
it was just a very friendly environment
very nice and by
if i remember correctly it was somewhere
in the middle of the mountains
which was really nice to see okay
so um if we got it ready
and i was prepared for i mean i knew
what i wanted to play because
back in 2015 i was still uh
experimenting with do i want g6 do i
want e6
so i decided to go for this and
um bishop b4 queen c2 i
i kept on playing this bishop before
until
2017 when i faced some
um some difficulties
in a game that basically all the game my
opponent was better
and there was nothing i could do about
it so i kind of
switched to girlfield and now i'm in
between
growfeld all the time so we'll see we'll
see how it goes in the next tournament
uh all right so bishop before castle
and so now well i'm kind of waiting for
opponents to push for this d4 so we get
to
this classic nimble indian style and
then when there's d4
i'm hoping that i'll have this set up so
i could do nice e4
but with this uh with without d4
kind of nimzo so starting from reti then
like
um doing c4 and then
not doing this d4 kind of gives white
the chance to play d3 and stop all of
this whole
nice e4 shippings so
that's something else to
keep in mind um from
we are kind of uh going over a game that
i played
in 2015 against a grandmaster
back in 2015 i was not any kind of
grandmaster
and not back in 2015
i got my woman international master and
then 2016 i got the one woman jam
i am and the video trainer so 2016 was a
very
title full year for me um
and then 2017 i became a student and
hopefully next year i'll be getting a
degree from there
so different degrees but okay
so um my first question to the audience
how do you want to get your pieces up so
what is what setup do you guys want to
play
v6 bishop b7 d6 e5 you have some
different ideas so which one would you
prefer
i see some iranians in the chat nice
nice
so any suggestions so far okay d5 is
also a possibility but
my problem with d5 is always how you're
going to get this bishop out
because if like you could do d6
b6 and then get the bishop out from the
g4 or b7
but with d5 i'm a little skeptical on
what to do with this bishop
so um yeah i think
trying to get the bishop out from the
queen side might be the easiest way
i really wanted to get this e5 done so i
played d6 my ideas if you play d3 i'm
gonna play e5
and uh well we'll see how it goes i
don't really have this knight e4
anymore but i still do have a nice idea
of bishop g4s
if you um start trying to do something
with e4s which is not
necessarily good because you give up the
d4 square two bishops you need to open
the center not close it like this
so then i guess i could try to use my
knights
more um in the game he played e3 which i
simply assumed he wasn't he didn't want
to like show his hand if he's going to
play
um d3 or d4 just yet
i was pretty clear i want e5 i'm gonna
do e5 and
then this nice c6 um i'm not necessarily
sure
if knight c6 is the best idea
so my idea with my c6 was if you allow
me i want to play e4 i want to play
knight e5
i'm gonna come do stuff in the
in the center with my knights so
also keep in mind right now this is a
blunder
so either he gotta play e4 or
d3 or bishop e2 uh these are like
three top choices um
in the game he went for bishop b2
which i can only assume um now if it's
white to move white could play bishop d3
because if e4 now he can take it
because i can't take back the g7
square is falling i don't really want to
get mated so fast
so i think bishop b2 had that tiny trick
behind it
so now black to move again how do you
want to follow up
do you want to try maybe get this bishop
out do you want to get the queen out
do you want to just like play a5 and
attack b4
so here are some ideas how do you want
to
[Music]
continue for this
oh hello yeah i haven't been on twitch
in a while
so i haven't been giving you guys news
either
there is a slight chance that i am
allergic to my cat
um they are doing some slight enlisting
they're doing some tests
to see if that is true or not because if
it is true then my life is going to be
very complicated
so yeah i've i've been having like
swollen eyes a lot of sneezing
so we'll see we'll see but that's the
that's the newest weekly news with dorsa
since we haven't been on twitch just as
often
all right so i'm getting some good um
good recommendations on bishop
f5 uh i guess
trying to do a nice e4 f5 i think knight
e4 is a little bit
too ambitious because knight d4 is just
gonna move the queen
at f5 uh this is not very ideal because
well
he he's the one who has two bishop so he
wants to open up the center so you gotta
kind of
um be careful about that so
if like if this pawn was on d5 then yeah
f5 would have been
a little bit more interesting but with
d3 i wouldn't really start thinking
about it
just so quickly so i went for bishop g4
and so my idea of bishop g4 is pretty
clear
i am threatening to mess with your pawn
structure
so i kind of want to take this i want to
start getting the queen out and
it's i don't think that if you played
like h3 i wouldn't necessarily
um just take on f3 like
so yes i did play bishop g4 with the
intention of taking on f3
but it's not like whatever you do i'm
gonna take on f3 like if you play h3 i
could take i could play bishop h5
um take take we do give this file
um so that's something to see if this is
a good trade-off or not
you could just bring the knight but i
don't think this is what i wanted to go
for
bishop g form was more just a threat
than
a serious um serious
problem for white so after bishop g4
he just played bishop v2 logical just
developing so now what
how do you want to try and push do you
think e4 is a good idea
so my question is basically what do you
think about e4
because with e4 and the knight moves
then you could potentially take on e2
and as you can see then the d3 square is
becoming
a nice jumping spot so
what do you think is e4 a good idea
but i also really kind of do miss our
twitch channel
having the regulars i see some of the
regulars here as well
but yeah i
don't um i don't have the luxury
of playing chess as much since the
semester started
and um i also started my mcat prep
for the non-americans mcat is the exam
you do to get into the medical school
signed up for classes the books came
today
huge books it's a sack of this much
the weight of it was 17 pounds
so yay
all right so i see that e4 is something
that you guys are
actually thinking about it so
okay um okay i think you're right e4 is
a good choice
uh the the thing with e4 is that
um he has limited choices either knight
d4
or something trying to tricky to be
tricky and play like b5
but with b5 because if you take on f3
now then he's gonna take it back with
the pawn
you save your bishop and he's gonna take
over here and
now there's two bishops
oh and this open file and
open center so that's something that
white would prefer to have compared
to most positions in
this game so b5 is a little tricky just
trying to see if
i'm going to make a mistake or not if he
played knight
d4 then what do you guys want to do
shall we take on e2
and try this or should we just take on
d4
so yeah what do you want to do
um knight g5s i i don't know which
position you're exactly talking about
thomas but um
knight g5s if you were mentioning it
here then the e2 i would just simply
take on e2
yeah i think bishop e2 is the easiest
way like you could do knight e5 right
now
but then you have to deal with some f
trees or some f4s
it gives white some fighting chances we
don't really want to give those fighting
chances
so i agree let's take over here
after take back then we can do this
knight e5s
and then um knight f4
seems to be the only move to defend d3
now i'm thinking can i just play g5 and
then try and check i
know i don't really want to do this g5
it's kind of
this really does scare me um
maybe maybe just
i can just get the queen out
you can just simply develop i generally
like this position more they feel like
the queen and the bishop are
kind of misplaced they're attacking
nothing
so all right um
yeah uh now let's go back to b5 because
i do think that b5
is the best one and the trickiest one so
um let's just keep looking at this all
right so after b5
um we got to do this knight e5 because
as also mentioned in the chat
uh if we were to simply take over
here then we have to deal with
oops not that that would be great then
we have to deal with
um depending on where you place your
bishop i don't necessarily think it
matters
that much but now you have some serious
issues like how are you going to
cover all of these weak squares like
okay king is eight
now i can just do like bishop d3 and
next i could even try to do like king d2
double up the rooks the king is very
safe on e2
for that i would refer you to the
lecture we had
a few weeks ago about should be castle
or not
uh all right so yeah he takes f3
after b5 would simply give white
what it wants so knight e5 is the right
tool
so after knight e5 my opponent did take
on e5
and now we gotta take that because
if we were to take on e5 now bishop
takes here
and it could be just h3 and then this
pawn falls
right yes exactly
yeah chad you guys are all you're doing
very well
all right um so gotta take on e2
uh we could consider some um
intermediate moves with knight f7 i do
think
king take e2 might have been the
the best way for white and just try to
develop just try to like play d3 and do
like the fake castle
i think this would have been the best
way for white to
have it but in the game um my
grandmaster opponent just played knight
takes f7
so i gotta take it back because my queen
is under attack
and now so now um
this king is in the middle of the center
uh without much shelter and
yes give him a few moves is gonna do the
fake castle
but now it's black to move so how can we
use this
king weakness
exactly exactly knight g4
so just like simply and the problem is
compare this position
to if he took king takes e2
first and saved the tempe
by playing rook d1 see in the game he
took here
and now it's my turn and i also have
this open
file so that's why we shouldn't always
eat the free stuff
even though i do recommend always eat
free stuff not necessarily always think
about it and try to evaluate the
position
but because if you don't think about the
free stuff for example if you didn't see
this pawn take you wouldn't have
realized that all right so this pawn
take is not
the most accurate because you end up
giving
black some nice chances so he
he just put f4 now how do we follow
all right great i already seen chad
people are mentioning it before me
asking so i'm just going to go ahead
and say yes to queenish4
so our idea is pretty simple i want f2
um in the game you played ricky one now
if i
do this queen f2 he's just gonna run
away and my queen is kind of like
awkward placed here like yes i could
try to maybe take the pawn but it
doesn't make any sense why would i
give my opponent's chances to just like
why would i like
push the opponents to run away so this
doesn't make much sense to me i wouldn't
have done queen f2
um so what do you guys think we should
do now
oh i just got an email from talia if you
are somewhere watching
thanks for the email um
so we do have like two or three
i want to say like one really
interesting move the other one is
um also acceptable
you could simply just like double your
rooks up that's also all right
like there's nothing wrong with it but
if you want to actually
play accurately um you have to think
about queenish five
uh the other move is a little bit more
tactical
so i'm gonna give you guys another maybe
30 seconds maybe a minute
to see if you can find it
so i didn't see this move in the game so
if you don't
see this there's nothing wrong with it
like
um a grandmaster is white missed it
i missed it
so it's not the end of the world but
okay oh i do see a few people mentioning
it
i don't know if you guys are just saying
it because it's funny
or no you're correct knight t5 is the
best one because you can't take it now
there's queen g4 checkmate
just like in the middle of the board
it's a very beautiful checkmate
if i ever end up writing a tactics book
this
this
one will definitely go in it i actually
have been
considering it but not this not 2020
i need to get done with my mcat monster
first
i need to ace that but
maybe next year so if you guys have
ideas i'm always open to it
all right but yeah knight e5 is um
quite interesting i didn't do this i had
like the similar idea so i played queen
h5
and the other beautiful thing about
knight e5 is that you are kind of
already jumping into d3 yes you want to
play queen g4 but even if not you do
have this knight d3 so like let's say
you move this stroke so no more
checkmate now you get knight d3
and now this knight is becoming a
nice monster right now queen g4
coming up like h3 seems to be the only
move now i can simply
just um i guess push a6
or d5 or kind of just like double my
rooks
i think this is just very pleasant for
uh
black weiss doesn't necessarily have too
many moves
to do like kink he can't even play king
d1 because of knight f2
so i really do like this position
okay um let's
go back i just went with queenish five
queen five was interesting
oh sorry i wasn't talking i wasn't
thinking um if i did mention g6 i was
thinking about something like a6 or c5
not h6 i i did not really want to touch
my kingside pawns
especially with the queen on c3 so if i
did say it
it's a simple mispronunciation
but alright so quinash five now what do
you guys think white should do
um white should definitely try to get
some room for the king right so either
you gotta move this rook this trick is
quite misplaced in e1 i don't know why
he played rookie one
so maybe like either rook g1 now i do
knight e5
you could play g4 so if i take it
now this knight is also kind of penned
so that would be interesting
um i think maybe rook g1 is the
the easiest way to continue this game
but
keep it king f1 okay so king f1 now what
shall we do
as black you can see that we are
pawn down but we do have a quite nice
piece coordination so
i'm not the biggest fan of knight h2
because if you play knight h2 it feels
like you are already like giving up
um knight h2 king g1 then what are you
gonna do yes you
kind of have to play knight f3 take take
and i don't think you have anything more
than a perpetual
so yes to queenish for
yeah queen h4 is great again knight e5
would have been
interesting as well i just went with
queenish for
and he played king e2 and at this point
i was like
you know what let's repeat and i repeat
it
and he just played rookie two but um
like she
offered to draw and i accept it but i
kind of do regret it i've shown some
other games that i've accepted draw and
then i regretted it
so i don't i hope
i wouldn't accept the draw now
if i was playing someone definitely the
fact that he was like 300 points
more than me had um some say in
my decision but at the same time
i didn't really know how to continue
so i had some issues with converting the
advantage like i knew i was better i
just
couldn't necessarily convert it so
i just kind of repeat it um actually
funny after rook e2
knight h2 is interesting because now we
get queen g4
i think i thought that's worth
mentioning um
okay so
let's just okay so this was the end of
this game
i do want to show you another game
that i prepared
and i was black again and this was 2016
so this was like maybe six months after
the previous game so i told you that i
was kind of
trying to figure out if i prefer e6 or a
pepper for g6 style
so um this was my
during that struggle as well i was
playing a closed round drawing
tournament
in belgium one of the first close
tournaments i ever played
i didn't end up scoring a norm there but
i ended up playing for their team for
the season so i guess well kind of a
all right i mean i would prefer norm but
well
wasn't co i didn't come back completely
empty-handed i did get some good games
so this was one of them uh i was playing
uh
peter hopeman i think he will he's an
international master
i might be wrong but i remember that he
i know that he was higher rated than me
at the time not much maybe like by 50
points
okay so during the struggle that i was
facing in 2015
sick and 16 on do i want g6 or do i want
e6 um this
game resulted in g6 so let's try to see
how did my fight with myself go so
we have a nice king's indian classic
right
so um hold on i think
there might
oh yeah okay um so bishop e2
is one of the uh games that i had
i had some other whoa no let's give out
the ending
i had some other games as well so
somebody that played h3 against me
that's a different story um i had
another game that after bishop e7 e5
someone played castle instead of bishop
e3 that this game
was um played
by bishop e3 so does anybody actually
play this
who plays king's indian
ah hi josh are you here as
um with your sword for the knife
all right so i can see that there are
some people who
uh play this line obviously some people
are
playing there's so many lines anyways um
so
this king's indian is one of the uh
most common positions because
well we kind of have to start preparing
an attack
this is like the style with black i'm
gonna go
kill you in the king side you're gonna
kill me in the queen side let's see who
can
kind of like win this game faster
okay so um so far
so good everything seems to be normal
we got this f5 i do have this nice
little threat of f4 give me that bishop
for free
uh obviously didn't f3
and okay so so far everything is normal
right
white is preparing to open up over there
i'm preparing to open up
in the king side and so my first
question to you
when white is attacking in the queen
side in this type of pawn structure
especially king's indian or some rule of
us
what should we do should we just mind my
mind your own business and should you
just push
or should you play something with b6 or
a5 or c6 like should you poke it back
okay so i have one ignore
let's see what josh will say after all
he
pretty sure he's the highest rate that's
watching right now
that is true before you could do some a5
stuff
okay so we're getting a lot of poke back
so um far back not necessarily it would
be a good idea if we could actually
stop this attack in the queen side and
then attend king's side with an
[Music]
east mine but it's not necessarily we
can always achieve that
so i played b6 which
i'm not entirely sure about potentially
a5
is another idea because if you take
now i can try c5 and my idea is i just
wanna like
lock this part up as well lock it up sit
and watch
so um that is kind of why
i um i
really didn't i wasn't really sure i
just think it's so hard
to make these decisions on a5 b6
ignore c5 so i just went for b6
um i do believe that i looked at this
position
prior to the game not necessarily like
right before but
um all right so in the game you played
c5 what do you think about c5 good
bad accurate
um can black slow it down
well i mean ideally we just want to stop
it not even that
um
oh that would be nice if i could play
almost like an engine
my life would be so much easier
now the question is can i use the same
engine in my real life problems and not
just chess
but all right um now i'm just
daydreaming
okay so after i think c5 is alright
might be slightly premature
because like i think knight b3 would
have been a nice preparation
so c5 is all right though it's not um
it's not a bad move
so after c5 km i was gonna say take
we can take so what do you guys think
about take and
which one should we take or does it even
matter
so do you guys want to try and do some
exchange on c5 or do you want to ignore
it and play
rook f6 like i did
um so
i do you think that's necessarily not in
their c6 that rook f6 is not necessarily
the best move
because um it
would again it would be pleasant if we
already had
fixed everything in the um
in the
queen side i can't find words not
necessarily sure why
for that as well all right so if we take
on c5 take and take back
uh let's say take take now i
kind of do prefer white's pawn structure
and um i am like if this bishop was in
d4 then no no i
absolutely prefer black but this bishop
is also troublesome
what are you going to do after knight c4
so knight comes to c4
now um you can't even use this d6 square
i don't know i yeah it's just kind of
like i feel like if i
um if i played like this i might as well
just be like
bowing my head toward the opponent
already so
i uh after c5 i just played rook f6 in
the game
uh
i don't have a full
rationale on what i was thinking but
what i am thinking now
is that rook f6 does kind of go
hand in hand with this type of attack
because you do want to try
and just attack as much as possible as
strong as possible um so
rook f6 was all right also if you play
c6 now i have knight
f8 so there is another square for the
knight compared to having to go back to
f6
um so these are some stuff to consider
now i could also
think about getting my queen out that
way
okay so in the game he didn't play c6 he
went queen b3
now um also also
in most of these type of pawn structures
um from what i've realized you either
want to take over here or you don't if
you want to take over here
then you have to keep an eye out for
when it's the right time to take it
if not i didn't want to take it over on
c5
so i was just ignoring it i wasn't
looking for it every every move unless
something changes like unless he pushes
this pawn or moves this bishop
whoops that would be illegal if he did
something dramatic then
yes i would consider um taking over here
but if not
if the pawn is still here if the visual
is still here i don't think i would
waste much
time and effort considering what to take
when to take
so after queen b3 um you got to make up
your mind either you want to take c5
and you want to go into that interesting
position
with um some uh
issues with you know what we were just
looking at
the double pawns and knight c4s and this
week pawn
or either you want to try your chances
here
or you don't and you just ignore this
whole taking on c5
okay so um i just played drug h6
i just i am going for your king and i'm
going to
get that king sooner or later
okay um so another thing to mention
is this idea with drug c1 for those of
you who play this as white
is good so you could consider this
something with like
play rook c1 trying to do knight c4
because white's game is basically in the
queen side so as long as you are
advancing your queen side and you're
making some trouble in the queen side
i do agree with that
um okay so receive one there is a
question about taking it once and not
twice so if you take you are still
giving
your opponent some chances so um let's
say you play like rp8 in this specific
position
and you still don't want to take on c5
now he could try and take and take on
here and then he also has this past pawn
so i would prefer not to give too many
chances
but that is my chest philosophy the less
chances i give the better
so in this position i actually played
slightly inaccurate and i did asics
it's not like a blunder it's not a huge
deal i was kind of hoping that it would
provoke him to try and close this part
up
which it didn't um he took on d6
and now i was quite happy because if you
play here i have
uh a5 if you play something like knight
a4
i could think about b5
and you gotta move that knight away
again and okay so
in this position we are finally getting
some
stability so finally the queen slide is
somewhat stabilized uh this trick is
pretty strong so we gotta keep an eye
out for that
your rook is kind of awkwardly
misplaced but i can't
help it much at the moment we can't
simply try
and bring more pieces to the king side
and that is what i did as well
so i'm bringing queen e8 and as soon as
i can queenish five
and seems that my my attack is
stopped right but that is not that is
not correct
we are still far far away far far away
from
an attack being stopped so knight f6
and finally knight e4 so my question to
you guys
do you think this position is
good for black or did knight e4 just
give white some interesting chances so
basically white
to move are you gonna take that back
do you think knight e4 is a strong move
or is it just a bluff
anybody wants to give it a try
anybody wants to take on e4 because if
you don't take an e4
you kind of just gave that gave up that
pawn and now my knight on e4
is going to take on f2 or just come back
play e4
play g4 so you have a serious choice to
make
either you're going to take that knight
and call my bluff
or
it is actually just true it is a kind of
huge bluff because
take take on e2 i'm attacking
absolutely nothing yes i'm attacking
potentially e4
i might want to push some pawns but at
the same time we have rook c7
what am i to do with this knight the
thing is if i
move the knight now uh you're gonna do
like something like queen c4 and try
and threaten me with exchanging queens
and also
my precious bishop if i try to save it
again i'm getting destroyed in the queen
side
so it's i'm actually getting destroyed
like there's no way out
um yeah we are gonna try to do b takes
asics that is the idea of wanting to
exchange the queens
to have a super easy end game for white
so knight takes e4 was a bluff
good on those of you who saw it if you
didn't don't
worry too much about it my opponent
didn't see it either
he assumes that knight e4 he blundered
and and he just started it actually they
started showing in his face he started
to get
stressed and um it was quite nice to
see that my bluff was working so
after knight takes e4 the best is to
take back
but he didn't he played bishop b6
and now this gives me some new chances
what do you think is the best move for
black now
so now black to move how can we continue
this bluff
good thank you 92 great tactic
good eye so in 92 you can't really take
it
because if you take now i have queen
takes h2
and i'm not going to give you this check
because
well i mean i could but i would have to
repeat
so now we're just going to play queen g3
i have much stronger threats
also knight f5 coming up bishop h3
coming up
everything everything uh you play sounds
like bishop g1 i'm just gonna
go there and simply just gonna
put more pressure put more pressure and
finalize this with the knight
so yes um i did play knight c2 in the
game
i wasn't going to miss my chance after a
huge bluff
and the game we went for a queen c2 now
we have a clear advantage um well you
kind of do have to take on f1 because
to something like e4 or g4 could work
but at the moment you have to decide on
keep not giving the knight up for free
which
seems to be something that a lot of
players keep missing like
with some of my students when they when
they get like a better position
let's say they're like a rook up they
decide to sacrifice a bishop
for nothing not even like an advantage
just like give it back because it
kind of looks good so for those of you
who are
um still making the transition from
beginner to intermediate or intermediate
to advanced don't give up stuff for free
always have a plan so let's keep
eating up we i took on f1 and
i simply took on h2 i think taking on d5
is something that could potentially work
in the future
but not right now because of all the
potential
issues that will follow so
i just simply took on h2 and i have a
clear idea i just want to
play queen g3 rick h1 knight f5
so bishop d3 stops whoa that is illegal
he stops my knight f5 ideas so
now why the black to move how can we
continue
our attack you can see that black is
much better you can
see that you want to be black you want
to go poke around with all of those
squares
but right now you can't so black tell me
what to do
okay so i see some interesting ideas
between mainly
g4 queen g3 yes g4 is the best one
i think when g2 is also interesting but
g4 is something that you just gotta do
is you can't
um you can't just not do this g4
so uh g4
in the game he played queen f2 which i
can only assume was
to stop my queen g3 and my queenish one
ideas
but you can simply take it over here um
he can't really take it with the pawn
because there are
so many different ways to win right now
i'm kind of stunned by
which one to choose there is an e4 which
is quite interesting
if you take take um
now this is under attack this guy's
under attack
so i wouldn't even know which to choose
um
i think the simplest way is to actually
do this e4 and just
get it over with or you could take that
and do
like breakage twos or you could
if taken with bishop do this e4 again
it's just super winning
so he had to take with the queen
now what shall we go for the same idea
should we try with e4 or do you want to
try do you see something stronger
i kind of do like e4 and i did play e4
in the game
you could try like bishop f5 and
exchange the bishops and get the knight
in the game but i think e4 is just the
easiest way to win
eat up as much as you can so now after
queen takes e4 are you going to take on
b2
or do you see something stronger
oh i see someone saying f3 nice nice
good job on f3
so f3 is the best one um
so after f3
you have a very clear idea you want
mates right i'm going to do like maybe
two maybe three
so he has to do something to defend it
and he can't just take it back
because now i think rook f6 is the
easiest way to win
can't take it back with the pawn because
well b2 is falling and there's also a
bishop h3
so after after in the game we put drixty
two
take take bishop h3 let's pick up as
much as material as we can
um i think a2 was just like a desperate
trying to keep this
but i honestly can't
um i don't think white
could hold this position even if i like
okay i don't want to say if i blundered
some pieces even if i played inaccurate
i don't think white could defend this
position
because well it's like a free
rook at this point
and okay so
i think just bishop c3 it should be
enough as well bishop c3 and then king
does a move
then another check oh this is way too
winning and again i just so i was like
okay
let's eat a little bit more uh material
and i simply just went for
this position like you take back and i'm
just eating that as well
so he just resigned now um
so i do feel like this game was kind of
decided on the bluff that i did knight
takes e4 so
laughing is good as long as you know
that you know what you're doing
and
[Music]
you can't bluff then you should i've had
experiences that i try to bluff
and my like i've seen people like
make a mistake and then at this like
they realize it's a mistake and they
like their body language shows us so
visibly like they just like start
shaking their head or like they throw
the pen
or they you just you just know it from
their face and then you start looking
for what's wrong
so if you are one of those people try
and improve that because
your opponent can read body language
most likely so this kind of reduces your
poker face so
yeah the psychology lesson of the today
bluffing is fun improve your poker face
and i hope you guys enjoyed this two
games
i really like them hopefully we'll have
more interesting games with a nice
backstory
for next week i think i am doing the
friday classes as well i think they're
they're on twitch so if you want to see
more lessons from me
make sure to tune in for friday and
with that uh my as my
final bluff no not a bluff but i'll hand
you to josh
should be starting momentarily as soon
as i
finish bluffing i mean talking
alright have fun everybody see you later